celle que nous appellerons emilie est
une enfant de la dpj
nous ne pouvons identifier ainsi que ses
parents d'accueil le champ beau chant
haut c'est le parent même car son enfant
avec un petit bagage parfait à deux ans
et demi elle a déjà passé plus de la
moitié de sa courte vie ici comment ça
s'est passé les premiers temps une
petite boulette le marché peut pas
encore le premier soin on était assis
ont joué à s'élever bien marché elle
jamais pleuré jamais puis elle avait
tout on a d'autres enfants des bois puis
actuellement la petite vedette que pour
elle c était facile aux de les adapter à
tous mais la tap
emilie est in ou sa famille d'accueil ou
six de la même communauté sur la côte
nord une famille accrédité par le centre
de protection de la jeunesse c'est suite
à une annonce il avait été fait à la
radio comme de quoi puis qui manquait
des familles d'accueil
ap st mitigé qui avait comme jean le
christ qu'il fallait qu'il passe des
jeunes en réserve un certain extérieur
et par des îles perdaient leur langue
perdaient leur culture veut pas leurs
idées d'erasme et puis c'est une manière
à nous on donne un coup de main
beaucoup d'amour à donner on avait en
avait de la place dans votre maison mais
il ya un hic pour s'occuper d'emilie ils
reçoivent moins d'argent que les autres
familles d'accueil québécoise deux fois
moins 20 36 + 5 dollars le 6 dollars par
jour au total 31 dollars et 36 par jour
une famille d'accueil québécoise reçoit
plus du double au minimum 71 dollars par
jour selon les barèmes de la fédération
des familles d'accueil
et si la famille d'accueil permettez-moi
blanche la québécoise une ville reçoit
un enfant autochtone zone de la
contenant d'une des réserves de lakota
combien cette famine parle souvent un
jeune qui est placée directement par le
centre jeunesse ou encore que ce soit un
jeu qui provient d'une réserve
autochtone ça changera pas son montant
donc c'est vraiment elle va vous
recevoir le même montant si c'est un
jeune d'une communauté ou si c'est d'un
jeune qui vient d'une ville voisine
autrement dit si emilie était placé au
village voisin
sa famille d'accueil serait mieux payés
qu'ici sur la réserve des familles
d'accueil ils nous ont découvert cela
dernièrement chez absolument injustice
moi je trouve que c'est on a suivi les
mêmes critères d'admission pourrait pour
être famille d'accueil on a forcé les
montages de la mancha mais enfin c'est
le même a faim le mou s'est répandue la
colère aussi
c'est carmen inscrits minassian pis ça
m'enrage savoir si nous ont brillé lors
ce qui en fait leur nouvelle loi ils
n'ont pas tenu compte des familles
autochtones
oublier le mot revient souvent et
effectivement les autochtones ont été
oubliés lorsque les familles d'accueil
du québec ont pu se regrouper et
négocier une convention collective
il ya trois ans c'est l'étonnement du
côté de la fédération
et quand même inquiétant puis pour nous
c'est problématique parce que c'est sûr
qu'au bout de l'allée oui c'est la
famille d'accueil qui reçoit moins mais
au bout de la ligne c'est le jeune qui
est placé dans la famille d'accueil qui
perdent 1 pourquoi cette différence de
traitement
une famille québécoise est payé par le
québec la famille autochtone par le
fédéral même si c'est québec qui lui
donne son accréditation et les barèmes
ne sont pas les mêmes
des familles autochtones ont demandé
conseil à un avocat que c'est la faute
du québec que ce la faute fédéral c'est
la faute à ni un ni l'autre qui leur
permet bien sûr de continuer à sous
financé puisse renvoyer la balle à
l'autre par là que les familles
d'accueil
elles se sentent pas respectés se sente
mise de côté sans qu'on les traite comme
si c'était moins bon goût est capable
qu'une famille hors réserve d'accueillir
des enfants
20 communautés autochtones du québec
sont dans cette situation et
ironiquement ce sont celles qui ont pris
en charge une partie de leurs services
sociaux plutôt que de dépendre
entièrement des centres de protection de
la jeunesse comme si l'autonomie amenait
le sous-financement gouvernements
fédéral et provincial ont un devoir de
consulter au niveau des premières
nations
donc lorsqu'il arrive un projet de loi
qui arrivent et qui est montée et qu'
aucune consultation préalable ou plus de
consultations on se retrouve dans une
situation comme celle ci mais moi ça
fait trois ans une éternité pour les
familles d'accueil qui ont des enfants
et qui s'en occupe à chaque jour c'est
souvent un système présentement avec
justement de la façon qu'elle kiki et
façonner un système qui des fois devient
un système de mesure et il y a plus pour
chaque enfant autochtone placés en
réserve
le fédéral rembourse entièrement le
québec selon les nouveaux taux mais
continue de payer les familles
autochtones
selon l'ancien barème le fédéral accorde
plus de mon temps aux pros bariz est
réduit au niveau des communautés
autochtones est acceptable
c'est inacceptable après l'indignation
l'amertume la qualité de vie dans une
communauté autochtone versus les
québécois et versus des canadiens et ses
progrès sans sa tour était un de fou sr
auto demeurer qu'importe le programme et
kate
car l'enjeu est de garder les enfants
dans leurs communautés dans leur culture
éviter les erreurs du passé
des centaines de familles d'accueil
autochtone espère la fin de la disparité
moi ce que je trouve le plus dur
personnellement ma sécu
fait sa peau pour aider ces on est par
amour on voulait garder les jeunes
c'était dans notre communauté de pas se
faire écouter
moi je trouve qu'on nomma corée mandat
de respect c'est l'attirer en soleil
enfin qu elle a valu d'être ça fait
partie de la famille tcc de la famille
puis on s'est engagée si c'était pour la
vide